you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
income that's not the point
the point is you have to sit down and
lay out a step-by-step game plan that
you believe in and that you execute on
and when you have a clear path that you
believe in and you execute on you can
win at almost anything you can you know
you can raise children you can have a
great marriage
you can keep your physical body in good
condition if you have a clear
step-by-step path that you believe in
and that you're willing to sacrifice to
execute on you can do almost anything
it's goal-setting is really what it is
but it's a matter of laying this thing
down and saying I've got a plan here and
I'm going to do this I'm gonna do now
I'm not going to try to fix the Dave
Ramsey system ten million people have
used it to get out of debt you don't
need to fix it don't be a freakin genius
you're the genius you got yourself into
debt so don't do that no instead just go
this works and we're gonna work it is it
going to be perfect no is going to be
perfect it's about your life but you've
got a plan that will work you do your
you know thousand dollar emergency fund
is baby step one the starter beginner
emergency fund baby step two is your
debt snowball listing all your debts
except your home smallest to largest
even if you've got a ridiculous but
student loan like that last lady even
then you put it on the list and then you
just beat the crap out of it man you
just go crazy you got to get fired up
and wired up you got to be so in tune
and so focused on getting rid of that
debt that's smallest debt that you're
broke friends are making fun of you if
you're if your family doesn't think you
need counseling you're not on track if
people aren't saying you joined the Dave
Ramsey cult you are not on track you got
out you got to change your way of
looking at things and change the way you
do things when you do that you
can do this stuff I don't care if you
make $23,000 a year or you make 2 or
$30,000 a year you can do this because
the beauty of getting rid of that stupid
debt is I don't care if you make twenty
three thousand or two hundred thirty
thousand dollars a year you can start
investing and jump into the 401k with a
little bit of match jump into a Roth IRA
and start becoming wealthy you get Chris
Hogan's retire inspired book you can sit
down you can lay out your riq you can
become a millionaire and you want to be
on Regis filming Philbin show to do that
you too can be a millionaire it's not
hype and it's not a microwave it's a
pain in the butt and it takes 20 years
but you're going to spend the 20 years
doing something else like being mediocre
anyway so don't be mediocre don't fall
for that crap don't walk around being
normal with a car payment in a boat
payment and a seadoo payment and a couch
payment and a student loan that's been
around so long you think it's a pet and
a pocket full of plastic so thick that
it causes your back to be out of whack
because your wallets so stupid don't be
normal normal sucks in America you don't
have to do this you don't have to live
this way you get to choose choose ready
set go this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you